[Applause]
what was your relationship like the two
of you once said most of the scenes we
did together we were either yelling at
each other or I was getting my ass
kicked so I had a lot of fun we were
friends my memory of working with moms
we were best friends
surprised to hear you say that they're
separated we have to talk after this my
first conversation about being Daniel
Larusso was with our director John
avildsen who I auditioned for and
instantly you could see these this
audition footage on YouTube you can find
it and it's the first time ever I ever
read the words to that character who was
Dani Weber in the script I joke when
they cast me they had to add a few
vowels who make an italian-american so
the conversation and in this video you
can see it's avildsen explaining the
character explaining what he's going
through explaining this story what's
happened terrific these kids that jump
came chase you and they beat Jeffords
just before
totally yeah the argue show sir but I
did remember John avildsen saying to me
I can't guarantee you anything right now
but if I were you I'd take some karate
lessons which doesn't often happen you
know a couple more hoops to jump through
and Here I am I got to be Daniel or so
[Applause]
my first conversation was I was called
in by the casting directors I had
audition for a different movie before
that that I didn't get and I threw my
manager I got a phone call to come in
and they want to talk to you so into
Columbia Pictures at that time I was in
my tank top ally I'm wearing a headband
I remember exactly but I went in and
they said you know this is movie called
Karate Kid we think you'd be great for
this part Johnny I'm like oh my god I
don't know karate I know how to run
their motorcycles but there was one
scene in this script that I really
connected to and somehow I just
connected to the character and I ran it
through my living room a bunch of times
and then the next day went and met John
Alton he was sitting in a chair has
camera you always have his video camera
film filming everything and it was a
scene cut out of the movie where I had
Daniel a death certificate at the water
fountain and I was like what's this for
and you gotta get your mommy to sign it
so you could be in the tournament with
the big boys and he says I thought I was
supposed to be no contact doesn't say
accidents happened and then I walk away
and he goes hey you think he might be
wrong and I go who through a sense that
you think he might be wrong and then my
line is watch your mouth [ __ ] so on
that line that's when I walked over to
John Allison and grabbed him what you
don't do and I said watch your mouth
[ __ ] and it kind of pushed him back
and then the room was still and that's
where the that's where the the scene was
supposed to end but everybody was still
watching me so I kind of impromptu went
to the door I said read it and weep I'll
see in the tournament and went out there
in the waiting room and came in took my
headband off which I was wearing yes I'm
sorry I'm sorry that was Billy that was
that was Johnny you know I'm Billy he
goes so how old are you and he got kind
of interested you know he's a little
taller than our kid like yeah well you
know Bruce Lee he still holler than
Bruce Lee Bruce Lee was smaller than
Kareem abdul-jabbar's I got a point yes
all right
thanks kid no was that sorry for the
long answer you can cut it you get a
great rise entertain the whole room
with pat morita everything he brought I
mean I was truly witnessing someone the
right actor in the right role never
taking it for granted
there was an ease of working with him in
those scenes up it's something relaxed
about it there was something when he
would talk to John avildsen or myself
about the headband which was called a
Hachi machi or something like I think
that's the correct pronunciation we
brought forth of using that taking it
out of his pocket and then when we put
it on it for training purposes and
that's when Daniel always wore it for
that all those moments and experiencing
him teaching us of that culture and
wanting to pay homage and respect to the
Japanese were in college at Okinawan in
this case he taught me that those
moments of ease that we had just fed
into the chemistry that we had that I
didn't even know we got you know the
movies so often thought of as pop
culture get him a body bag crane cakes
waxing on and catching flies with
chopsticks but it also has all these
other deeper elements to it which is why
what he taught me more than anything is
not to take things for granted you know
sort of revel in the opportunity that
you have so it just is one of those
meant to be partnerships I'm the lucky
one that's how I look at it I've met
Martin Cove as Crees in character as
crease so I never met the actor Martin
Cole Pat Johnson who trained us for the
further all the fight stuff he's a
referee in the Karate Kid film in the
red referee Buster before Martin was
cast
he played crease and he trained me as
crease and he would be super intense and
in-your-face and louder and bigger than
even Martin Martinez and so he put the
imprint of who crease was on me and then
when Martin Cole came in it was in the
dojo scene and it was the first time
we're meeting Martin Koch but I didn't
know if I knew his name this is John
crease and he came in character with a
black belt on for all I know he was the
real deal it was interesting there's a
cut this scene where Ralph walks into
the dojo
and you know and I kind of whispered to
him that he knows somebody's here and
enemy deserves no mercy what is the
problem is the Lawrence I mean you could
see that they had more of a relationship
than just you know setting you know
there was a personal relationship that
happened that's continuing now but you
know when he says to sweep the leg in
that moment
sweep the lick you know it was Marty
code that caused that reaction in me
which was just kind of to check him out
I mean he was so intense and so big so
he definitely drew out you know as any
actor that's a good actor he's gonna
draw out the best for me yeah I think if
I knew him as I know him now then I
might have laughed this no I'm just good
skin Marty you're a pushy little bastard
ain't you
[Music]
well elisabeth shue ali with an i she
was just coming out of the gate at that
point and John avildsen row he's
described he would always say to me he'd
see me and Lisa and we'll still call her
Lisa yes yeah she he would say you two
have no place being together it's like
it's like a strawberry shortcake and AG
anole listen I've been thinking maybe we
can call a truce yeah I'm not a war
excuse me we please finish the dance we
got along great she was she was tough
she was athletic she was a soccer player
oh yeah this is hell and you know and
she was just a just a kind of
all-natural girl and beautiful and cool
and we became friends of course the only
time I got connected in the whole movie
with a punch or a kick I never hit him
yeah Ralph never hit me think thank you
to everything no I think with the the
country club scene where Daniel comes in
and gets a spaghetti on me you know and
then I laugh and and Lisa every single
time she connected like boom at me she
would she could either you know Pat
Johnson's like no step back and swing
but I think every single time she hit my
jaw in fact when he's when Daniel falls
down the spaghetti and I'm laughing I'm
half laughing at the fact that she does
hit me yeah I haven't seen her in a long
time but who knows I may be seeing her
soon
it's like a wheat grain yeah it was
about a week we shot the all-valley
tournament yeah I remember it vividly
for us to perform that the first time
six cameras John avildsen who had
directed Rocky among others and so you
were in the hands of the best and we
filled up the arena with the extras and
they saw it for the first time and we
did it for the first time in front of a
crowd and that is a big part of the base
the spine of what that scene is that was
electric it was a it's completely it
changed from the rehearsals where we
were at one energy to step is like doing
theater I guess you step out and there's
the audience and it just brings you up
to a whole other place that you didn't
expect to happen and you could run into
trouble with the amount of adrenaline
because she's just so jacked up but we
was so well trained it really was you
know it was it was a tango I think we
did the whole fight seek I don't
remember shoe to get into locks I know
we went we went from the beginning of
the fight curtain to the end of the
fight it was live theater you're right
yeah it really rises that was it and it
was just you could feel it and in
between the breaks I mean when they
would say cut and I can look up and see
the fans like
[Applause]
you know they and my mom was sitting in
the audience and she's like please and
I'm like it's my baby
and there was actually some real martial
artists there real karate schools and
like a real mini tournament happening in
the background to make it look authentic
you know these kids and pads sparring
them so the environment was authentic to
what I had a real karate tournament
would have been like and then we step
out with our black belts that was the
time walking out with my black I'm such
a fraud right now you know they only
knew you don't want it in there like
who's that kid you know I meet the actor
that has done this for three months and
I hope I don't kick around the crane
kick I mean it was all that one low and
wide shot in the Karate Kid film and in
this Cobra Kai series you'll see there
are other angles and you could get a
glimpse of how many ways we shot that he
was a ladder just throwing the kick out
slow over and over in my face done more
and more yet haven't the water the one
they used was their low wide which is
the best choice
[Music]
and then it wasn't supposed to end that
way the film was not that's correct
originally on the script that's the
scene where crease chokes me out and the
Agee saves all of us and then they
lights were out after we finished the
tournament and John I wasn't said I got
my movie we don't need to shoot it and
yeah no but was interesting at that
point I believe at that point they said
listen if we ever do we could always
open a sequel with that scene and I I
don't know why but in my head I remember
hearing those words from whether it was
avildsen or Weintraub that their thought
was they were ahead of the game as far
as starting the the sequel you know
assuming we were gonna have a hit yeah
we were we hung around all the time we
were you know with the lunch every day
we trained together so we were we really
got into kind of a pack mentality and
you know and I would come in and Ralph
and I did our fight scene for the
tournament every day that we could you
know we had to take care of each other
in that way so I think John avildsen who
really created the chemistry by casting
all the right people for this it was
almost like you know he kind of created
this little universe for us you know we
became we've become closer friends over
the years and certainly since Pat Flynn
Pat passed away we became closer friends
just through have it the loss of him and
and moving forward and the fact that
this film has stood the test of time
it's just a big part of not only cinema
American cinema but also pop culture and
then here we are you know back again you
know in tandem so it's it's been quite a
journey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]